So now we have an understanding of our pawn types, controllers, animation, saving and loading,
the game world setup and other gameplay types that allow us to achieve our desired goals.
With all that in mind, we should maybe take a look to see if whether or not our technical designs need us to override any engine specific classes,
specifically the complex classes such as the game instance.
This is where the programming subsystems really do come in handy.
Programming subsystems allow us as developers to make use of instantiated classes
to implement functionality without needing to override engine classes.
The lifetime of a subsystem is managed. This means that we have a definitive start and end
that we can use to drive any functionality that we want.
The lifespan of a subsystem will vary depending on which subsystem you use, but we'll cover those in just a second.
So to put it into better context, let's say that we're considering a piece of functionality
and we've identified that the game instance fits our needs.
This is a really complex class and whilst it is perfectly fine to add whatever functionality we want,
it might bloat our class beyond what we really need it to, and if we haven't already overridden it,
then it might feel a bit overkill to override it to add our new functionality.
This is where the benefits of a programming subsystem come into play.
We can simply extend from a chosen subsystem class and piggyback on the back of that
for its initialisation to implement our own functionality.
Furthermore, programming subsystems provide easy to use extension points
where developers can get Blueprint and Python exposure straight away.
And it's all done without having to override any engine classes in the process.
So as we can see, the Unreal Engine offers us some supported subsystems straight out of the box.
And as can be seen here, all we need to do is identify our desired subsystem
and simply inherit from that class.
As we've discussed, programming subsystems have got a managed lifetime.
However, their lifetime will vary depending on which subsystem you use.
So if we take the Engine and Editor subsystems as an example,
these share common initialisation and de-initialisation points.
Both of their subsystems will be spanned up and spanned down
when their corresponding modules are created and turned down.
To give access to these in C++, we simply use the global GEngine
or GEditor pointers that are available to programmers.
As for the game instance subsystem, this is spun up and spun down alongside the game instance itself,
which we've already covered previously.
To grab a hold of the game instance subsystem, all we simply need to do
is grab a reference to the game instance from our world.
The local player is possibly a bit more unique
in that the local player is created when the player enters the world
and is held by the player's player controller.
It's worth noting that the subsystem will only exist on the server or owning client,
as the player controllers are not replicated to any remote clients.
Lastly, we can go over how to access a subsystem from outside of C++.
As we've already covered, programming subsystems can be accessed via Blueprint or Python.
Within Blueprint, all we simply have to do is grab our desired subsystem
and call whatever function that we have exposed for Blueprint to use.
As for Python, you can follow the example at the bottom of the slide.
It's important to note that the Python integration
is currently considered an experimental feature in the engine.
And that concludes introduction to gameplay in Unreal Engine.
Today, we learned about the core classes involved in Unreal's gameplay framework,
such as the player and player controller, as well as how to set up a game world.
We've looked at the basic building blocks of animation, such as montages and skeletons.
And we've learned about how Unreal handles input
and what systems Unreal provides when going about building our control schemes.
We've covered delegates and events,
as well as helper libraries that come with Unreal straight out of the box.
We looked at serialization before wrapping up with programming subsystems.
Thanks so much for watching, and have a fantastic day.